alors c'est hallucinant il y a
usurpation en fait d'identité de votre
personnalité du monde de c'est à vous
donc de France Télévisions de Bertrand
Chameroy et il y a toute une histoire en
fait qui raconte soit disant les
révélations de votre succès story que il
faut absolument investir dans des
plateformes comme polar BTC et c'est
incroyable parce que il y a énormément
de personnes qui sont en admiration
pour votre travail et donc ils sont
tombés dans le panneau et qui sont dit
parce qu'en fait vous tous les soirs
vous êtes à la télévision vous êtes un
peu comme le bon pote quoi voilà donc il
y a il y a un côté en fait de confiance
donc qu'est-ce qu'ils ont fait en fait
ils ont inventé une histoire comme c'est
quoi c'est moi qui parlerai en fait dans
l'article oui en fait c'est comme si
vous étiez invité sur le plateau de
c'est à vous et que vous avez révélé les
secrets de votre voilà de votre il n'est
pas du tout nécessaire de travailler
pour être et lorsque vous aurez pris
conscience de cette pensée vous
commencerez à avoir une attitude
beaucoup plus facile envers l'argent
donc là Bertrand Chameroy qui est censé
m'intervouer c'est facile de parler
quand on est une célébrité tous les
autres doivent souffrir chaque jour au
travail pour nourrir leurs familles et
tu sais quoi il n'y a jamais assez
d'argent de toute façon vous ne me
croyez pas donnez-moi 250 € avec la
plateforme granulator je vais gagner 1
million dessus en 12 15 soleils
c'est vraiment une manipulation
extraordinaire sur les réseaux sociaux
aux yeux de tous ou voilà
usurpation du monde de c'est à vous et
de vous-même et de d'autres célébrités
par d'autres publications sur les
réseaux sociaux alors ils vont très loin
parce qu'en fait là en fait ce qui se
passe c'est que après après l'article
explique que j'aurais pris le téléphone
de Bertrand Chameroy pour installer
l'application je viens de m'inscrire au
projet granimator grâce à votre
téléphone Bertrand cette plateforme et
la solution idéale pour ceux qui veulent
s'enrichir rapidement il est basé sur
une intelligence artificielle auto
apprenante qui fait des transactions de
crypto monnaie à votre place Bertrand
Chameroy me dit cela me semble très bien
mais combien vous pouvez réellement
gagner en réellement gagner en 20
minutes j'ai pris ton téléphone je me
suis inscrit sur la plateforme j'ai fait
un dépôt minimale seulement 250 €,
maintenant ouvrez l'application et
regarder combien vous avez pu gagner en
si peu de temps donc là il y a Bertrand
qui ouvre son compte sur la plateforme
et le programme à effectuer 3
transactions seulement 20 minutes 6
l'une d'entre elles n'a pas rapporté
bénéficie significatif mais les six
autres ont rapporté de bon profits le
sol des passer donc en quelques minutes
de 250 à 297 € et le faux article va
toujours plus loin puisque en fait il y
a Bertrand Chameroy qui me dit désolé
nous de recevoir un appel urgent de la
Banque centrale de France ils ont exigé
que nous arrêtions cette émission oui
c'est un scénario et donc en fait c'est
un scénario qui a été créé de toutes
pièces par des escrocs et ce sont
vraiment des escroqueries en bande
organisée parce qu'il y a plusieurs
escrocs qui qui sont sur le territoire
français et qui sont aussi à l'étranger
c'est incroyable alors Anthony Adriana
vous êtes victime de cette arnaque et
vous pouvez un véritable enfer
vous avez vu cet article comment vous
comme ça par hasard alors je l'ai vu sur
Instagram d'accord donc leur article en
fait il expliquait comment en fait il
disait que vous avez laissé votre micro
ouvert à la fin de d'une émission de
télé ah c'est ça le jour c'était du Off
ouais c'est ça c'est incroyable et que
vous donnez l'identité en fait de d'une
plateforme qui vous permettez de générer
plusieurs milliers d'euros par semaine
diabolique et donc
curiosité j'ai cliqué quoi pour voir de
quoi il s'agissait
et voilà je suis tombé sur la plateforme
polar BETC
je suis allé faire quelques recherches
pour voir s'il s'agissait pas d'une
arnaque j'ai rien trouvé au moment où ça
se passe j'ai rien trouvé
et du coup je décide d'investir
250 euros le minimum c'est ça comme on
dit communisme ouais voilà 250 ça
fonctionne sur la plateforme je vois que
j'ai des gains
enfin à échelle de ce que j'ai investis
et donc 300 euros quoi très vite comme
là comme ils ont dit là c'est déjà
énorme
combien de temps c'est l'hameçon
donc là vous dites quoi vous dites je
vais je vais
à ce moment là en fait je peux toujours
récupérer les gains d'accord donc ils me
font récupérer mes gains donc ça me met
en confiance bien sûr il y a un
gestionnaire de gestion qui me
contactent donc là quand il y a un mec
qui vous dit quoi je rentre en contact
avec une femme qui me qui m'expose un
petit peu tous les toutes les
autorisations de cette plateforme au
niveau légal quoi
et par la suite je suis mise en relation
avec un mon conseiller d'investissement
et voilà c'est comme ça que ça commence
et donc les mecs vous rappellent
derrière ils vous disent quoi là ensuite
j'avais 6000 euros et ensuite il me
rappelle il me dit écoute il me sera
fait j'ai une super opportunité pour
vous
il y aura certainement une grosse un
gros rebond sur le cours du pétrole
j'aimerais que vous intégriez le Edge
forme de Power BTC c'est à partir de
10000 euros non
en fait si je lui en parle mais je lui
dis pas que j'ai mis les 10000 euros
quand vous avez mis les 10000 euros
qui prévoyaient de gagner
minimum 6000 euros
sur le pétrole justement et à long terme
400 euros par semaine ce qui fait 1600
euros par mois
je me dis enfin c'est donc là vous avez
mis les 10000 euros
et donc là qu'est-ce qui se passe
et qu'est-ce qui se passe je donc je
gagne je gagne 8000 euros enfin sur la
plateforme je vois que je suis en que
j'ai des gay en fait 18000 vous êtes là
exactement je suis à 18000 euros
c'est bien d'investir mais à un moment
donné il faut quand même récupérer les
gars bien sûr du coup je fais une
demande de retrait de 1000 euros dans la
nuit et le lendemain me rappelle il me
rappelle complètement affolé il me dit
Monsieur Raphaël qu'est-ce que vous avez
fait
il faut me prévenir avant de faire des
demandes de retrait parce que les
demandes fallait retraits se font sur
les positions qui sont ouvertes et là si
c'est ce que je vois c'est inquiétant
donc je me rends sur la plateforme de
trading et je vois que j'ai une position
à moins 10000 euros donc à ce moment là
il me reste 8000 euros c'est 10000 euros
que j'investis les 8000 euros de gains
moi c'était 10000 euros je lui dis ben
écoutez si j'investis 10000 euros que
j'ai perdu 2000 euros c'est pas grave on
ferme la position il me dit si vous
fermez la position vous serez endetté de
100000 euros
100000 euros à polar Betis quoi avec les
effets de levier etc etc vraiment la
manipulation le cauchemar et donc
et donc il m'explique comme je fais
partie d'un d'un fond et que j'ai voilà
c'est c'est
un petit peu voilà j'ai des privilèges
entre guillemets il me dit qu'il a une
solution pour moi ça s'appelle le
freerisk et il y a moyen de fermer la
position
et qu'il faut réinjecter de l'argent
formidable
et là il me dit là il commence à jouer
en fait la course sensible commence à me
dire parce qu'en fait on avait j'avais
développé une si vous voulez une
relation courtoise avec ce monsieur je
comprends votre votre situation vous
avez une petite fille vous avez une
femme etc etc vous inquiétez pas tout va
bien se passer et donc à partir du
moment où il me dit ça je
c'est un niveau de malhonnête tiens en
fait qui bien sûr qui me dépasse en fait
et donc il me fait en crédit de 15000
euros donc je vois que tout se ferme que
tout rentre dans l'ordre entre
guillemets
et je leur envoie les 15000 euros donc
là à ce moment là je suis à 25000 euros
25000 euros ce n'est pas fini
donc là ça rentre entre guillemets dans
l'ordre donc je me dis va être c'est bon
je vais pouvoir récupérer mes sous quoi
et là il m'a expliqué qu'il faut une
taxe enfin voilà pour récupérer l'argent
il y a les impôts je sais pas quoi il
me dit
il faut remettre 10 euros
si vous voulez
je commence un petit peu à compter
et je commence à me dire que en fait
l'argent qui meurent sur mon compte
c'est plus que mon argent c'est-à-dire
que c'est l'argent pour payer le loyer
c'est l'argent pour payer vos économies
mes économies c'est pour payer la
matière de ma fille c'est pour vous donc
je lui dis je lui ai dit je peux pas
t'envoyer 10000 €. je peux t'envoyer
maximum 5000 €
et il me dit et là il me rejoue la même
la même la même mélodie quoi il me dit
écoutez votre votre histoire me touche
beaucoup
je vous ai dit je suis aussi peur de
famille etc etc je comprends je
comprends je vais voir ce que je peux
faire pour vous il me dit qu'il va voir
avec le département des avocats le
département juridique de la société
et il me rappelle quelques temps plus
tard il me dit écoutez c'est bon j'ai vu
avec eux on a trouvé une solution donc
ce qui va se passer vous allez mettre
5000 euros je vais mettre 4900 euros de
ma poche
et il m'explique qu'il peut pas mettre
plus de 50% de 10000 euros sinon c'est
considéré comme du blanchi
blanchissement d'argent blanchiment
d'argent
et donc ça évite les cinq missions
et là donc là encore une fois je me dis
c'est bon je vais pouvoir récupérer mon
argent
et là il y a l'avocat qui qui rentre qui
rentre en jeu en fait l'avocat de la
boîte et autant mon conseiller mon
soi-disant conseiller était pas du
respectueux mais courtois
jusqu'à je vous donne jusqu'à demain 15h
pour envoyer 5000 € etc là je peux pas
en fait je peux plus donc j'en parle là
je suis un petit peu mélangé par les
émotions bien sûr
et à ce moment là en fait je comprends
je me dis que un avocat digne de ce nom
ne parlait pas comme ça
Adriana ou Adriana vous en a parlé en
fait il m'en parle c'est à ce moment-là
en fait quand on lui demande en fait de
réinjecter encore cette somme là les
choses ont pris une toute autre ampleur
ils reviennent du travail je le vois qui
fait des cent pas et donc là je me dis
en tout cas réservé de base donc je me
dis il va finir par revenir en parler de
lui-même c'est ce qui finit par faire et
là il s'effondre il me dit là c'est la
catastrophe je lui demande ce qui se
passe je comprends rien parce que du
coup moi il m'en avait parlé en amont de
ce cette opportunité mais j'avais pas
plus d'informations que ça je m'y
connais pas en fait dans ce domaine là
et là il me débat tout tout ce qui s'est
passé tout ce qui est en train de se
passer et cette menace avec ce délai
jusqu'à 15h le lendemain et là je lui
dis mais en fait si tu demandes à être
remboursé en fait et qu'on te demande de
réinjecter 5000 euros pourquoi ne pas le
déduire de la somme totale au final et
envoyer finalement la différence si on
demande encore de réinjecter en fait
c'est tout le temps le même schéma on
demande de réinjecter et encore et
encore enfin 5000 surtout qu'il l'avait
dit au préalable que il avait pas cette
somme et là je dis stop je prends son
téléphone parce que pareil ils
arrêtaient pas de l'appeler le l'avocat
en question véreux au possible avec des
proposition
il a passé son nom
et donc du coup là je prends mon
téléphone je prends le sien parce que je
ne veux plus qu'il est de contact avec
ce monsieur et je je m'empresse en fait
de chercher un cabinet d'avocat qui est
spécialisé en fait le cabinet Ziegler le
cabinet Ziegler donc que je trouve en
premier justement qui est spécialisé
dans ce genre d'affaires et la prise de
rendez-vous pour le lendemain maître
Ziegler m'appelle et je lui explique et
il a fallu que je me le mettre sur
haut-parleur parce qu'en fait jusque là
Anthony pour lui c'était je voulais pas
y croire il voulait pas y croire en fait
il réalise moi tant qu'il n'avait pas
entendu que ce monsieur lui montait non
Monsieur Raphaël c'est une arnaque il
faut arrêter et vous viendrez demain on
en parlera
en fait alors il en est où aujourd'hui
vous en êtes où aujourd'hui donc on a
on a demandé au cabinetic lors de son
charger donc les il y a des dossiers
jury enfin juridiques qui ont été
envoyés à la banque les mises en
demeures donc
pour abus de confiance donc plein de
contre X aussi une recherche de
responsabilité de métaphores parce que
il y a aussi les réseaux sociaux qui ont
leur importance là-dedans il y a des
centaines de victimes en tous les cas
des centaines de signalements d'autres
milliers de victimes mais qui n'ont pas
contacté le cabinet Ziegler et
le préjudice en fait des victimes
condamnées ce cabinet s'élève à 6
millions 3 euros
donc j'ai eu des victimes au téléphone
qui ont perdu des 600.000 euros des
centaines des centaines
121.000 euros 30000 euros des petites
sommes pour la même chose pour ça
absolument absolument pour polar BTC ou
encore la plateforme FTM qui fait penser
plateforme fantômes donc voilà des
milliers de victimes
déjà avec moi alors je ne fais aucun jeu
jamais rien donc aucun truc donc déjà
vous savez déjà que c'est une arnaque
plein de téléphone pour des journalistes
avec un monde où
c'est n'importe quoi il y a d'autres
stars qui ont été oui en fait
en tous les cas Cyril c'est vraiment
toutes ces des scénarios mais il y a
d'autres personnes il y a Elon Musk par
exemple c'est des publications quand on
et je suis sûr que tout le monde a dû
tomber dessus en fait il y a Elon Musk
il y a
Kylian Mbappe il y a aussi
Bernard il y avait des voilà donc voilà
donc c'est ce genre en fait de de
publications
c'est la success story c'est les secrets
de réussite
les gestionnaires de gestion sont un peu
dans cette énergie un peu à l'américaine
de traders oui il faut investir c'est
maintenant le bon coup et il y a des
médecins qui sont tombés dedans il y a
des chefs d'entreprise aujourd'hui il y
a un chef d'entreprise qui était
propriétaire aujourd'hui il va bientôt
louer un appartement parce que voilà et
le monde a porté plainte aussi parce
qu'ils sont en fait là ce soir on a
cette affaire en exclusivité et donc je
pense qu'à partir de demain il y a
d'autres médias qui vont en parler
Anthony Adriana qu'est-ce que je peux
vous j'espère que je suis désolé parce
que vraiment ça vous êtes c'est
incroyable ça je vous dis je suis
vraiment désolé
la banque les recours que vous allez
avoir est-ce que ça ça se profile bien
pour vous non
alors pour moi les premiers responsables
c'est méta bien sûr parce qu'ils héberge
des escrocs
qui leur donne de l'argent bien sûr pour
pour diffuser en fait des escroqueries
escroqueries des gens voilà et quand
vous aviez monsieur au téléphone que
vous avez eu souvent est-ce que c'était
un téléphone à l'étranger où est-ce que
c'était en France c'est ici c'est
localisé au Royaume-Uni ouais
en ce qui concerne l'avocat Véro mais
par contre le conseiller en question
c'était bien le numéro de France avec
l'indicatif + 33 d'accord
chez le procureur de la République et
qui qui enquête sérieusement parce qu'en
fait c'est plusieurs expos des escrocs
qui achètent des données qui se
retrouvent sur le Dark web et ensuite
qui revendent à d'autres escrocs qui
sont à l'étranger donc c'est vraiment
comme on dit des escroquerie en bande
organique organisés c'est incroyable bon
on t'écoutez on va suivre cette affaire
on va essayer de faire le maximum pour
vous aider aussi parce que pour essayer
de voilà que ce soit ça va bouger
et n'hésite pas à venir n'hésitez pas à
venir témoigner en avance comme ça qu'on
fasse le maximum cette semaine voilà
parce que immersi arrive d'avoir vu
cette arnaque qui est incroyable Anthony
et Adrien j'aimerais tout faire pour que
vous récupériez votre argent mais ça va
être vous savez compliqué très compliqué
mais gardez le moral et je suis désolé
malgré moi c'est pas de votre faute
merci Anthony et merci Adriana d'avoir
été avec nous